so you're saying that what if he was not
out there screwing around with girls
would he have not been canceled you're
missing the problem he wasn't canceled
because he was screwing around girls he
was canceled because he was empowering
the male youth who was extremely
disempowered at this point in history at
the most men right now at the lowest
point in history period right the
average man has been completely defeated
he's addicted to drugs he's Addicted to
You Know corn you know he's addicted to
all these terrible things that are bad
for them and he is telling these guys
not being fat stop being a loser stop
being addicted to this stuff stop being
addicted to video games get out there
lift weights have some discipline be a
better person